el parlamento de sudáfrica amaneció en
llamas
enormes columnas de humo que escapaban
del techo fueron grabadas por decenas de
personas en la madrugada de este domingo
sin reporte de heridos y con la
incertidumbre que generan las causas del
origen de la conflagración ya hay un
arresto y una investigación en marcha en
el techo del edificio se ha derrumbado
por un lado y el fuego se ha extendido
al nuevo montaje según los agentes se
detectaron grandes grietas en la pared
lo que nos preocupa which is of
concerned las cámaras del parlamento
constan de tres secciones incluido el
edificio original y más antiguo donde
comenzaron las llamas una edificación
que data de 1884 con el avance del fuego
los bomberos desplegaron rápidamente un
cordón de protección que se extendió
hasta una plaza en donde todavía se
depositaban flores frente a la catedral
de san jorge' por el funeral de este
sábado del arzobispo desmond tutu
todavía estamos investigando lo que
causó el incendio y como el fuego que se
inició en la antigua asamblea se
trasladó luego la asamblea nacional
creo que hay alguien detenido ahora
mismo y está siendo interrogado pero
tenemos que profundizar más
la ciudad ya había sufrido un incendio
en abril cuando las llamas en la famosa
montaña de la mesa se extendieron por la
biblioteca de la universidad de ciudad
del cabo
lugar que albergaba una colección única
de archivos africanos ciudad del cabo de
la sede legislativa del país pero es
pretoria la capital ejecutiva de
sudáfrica el presidente tenía programado
un discurso en la sede del parlamento el
próximo 10 de febrero
ahora con el incendio también se
desconoce el lugar de la intervención